yes
of the 16 visits i made to latin america
in the caribbean as vice president
uh four of them were new mexico and i
was honored to meet you on
one of those visits mr president
during my visits i got to know mexico a
little bit and its people
and paid my respects to the version of
guadalupe as a matter of fact i
still have my rosary beads that my son
was wearing
when he passed and i walked the
beautiful and historic cobblestones in
mexico city
and spoke with mexicans of all walks of
life and i
treasure those memories and i hope
you'll be able to build on in the next
four years
is
mr president this is what i know the
united states and mexico
are stronger when we stand together
there's a long and complicated history
between our nations that haven't always
been perfect neighbors with one another
but we have seen over and over again
the power and the purpose when we
cooperate
and we're safer when we work together
whether it's addressing the challenges
of our shared border
or getting this pandemic under control
in the obama biden administration we
made a commitment
that we look at mexico as an equal not
as
somebody who is south of our border you
are equal
and what you do in mexico and how you
succeed
impacts dramatically on what the rest of
the hemisphere will look like
as you know the fastest growing
population in the united states is
hispanic and 60 of the hispanic
population is mexican-american
they're an integral part of our history
and i keep a bust to the civil rights
leader
chavez cesar chavez in my oval office as
a reminder
mr president i'm looking forward to our
discussion today
and to the many ways we'll have
to work together as neighbors and
partners in meeting our shared
challenges
thank you for doing this
foreign
those symbols
[Music]
foreign
is
[Music]
fundamentally
foreign
[Music]
historia
your heels
jorah
a
foreign
foreign
[Music]
is
america
foreign
when
i would like to start by thanking you
for your confession regarding your
devotion
we as mexicans respect and admire two
symbols they might be different
however they call to the plurality of
our country
one is the virgin of guadalupe as you
said and the other one
is benito juarez a liberal president
the best one we have ever had a
sacritech indigenous
that we are very proud of i would like
to thank you also for starting the
conversation this way
mexico
for stating that mexico is as important
to you
it is a pleasure to greet you it is
important that we base our good
relationships
on constant dialogue periodic
dialogue i know our relations in the
future will be
even better we are united by 3180
kilometers of border
but we are not only united by geography
we are also united by our economies
our trade our culture our history
and our friendship
we had a mexican president who dominated
the country for 34 years
very little time his name was porfirio
diaz
and he would say poor mexico so far from
god
and yet so close to the united states i
can now say
that it's wonderful for mexico to be
close to god and not so far from the
united states
i believe our countries will allow us
to develop jointly in these dire times
integration will strengthen both our
countries
as we are faced with this inevitable
expansion of
other regions our relations are
strategic
i would like to also thank you after the
call that we have had
for wanting to base our relations on
respect
and equality it is important for mexico
and we must keep on cooperating for
further development
based on independence and autonomy
potentializing what our peoples
mean to us
we are very thankful that you are
willing to maintain good relations
for the good of our peoples in north
america the canadian
the united states and the mexican people
well thank you mr president i'm going to
ask the press whether or not be kind
enough to
exit shortly here i appreciate it thank
you very very much
how about how about the program foreign
you